if I could just change your perspective
if I could just get you to realize you
have a whole other life to live I need
you to understand something you have so
much time us 50 year olds are gonna live
dramatically longer and healthier than
your parents and grandparents generation
so you sit here at 50 and as a child
what you grew up with you start
realizing like oh where am I in my life
middle tail end to middle it's hard for
somebody who's for thirty years gone a
certain blueprint to understand that
this is that realistic and they feel
like it's a young man support and it's
just not like it's just not
but what blows me away is how many of
you have decided that you're finished
dwelling on the fact that you didn't do
it in your 20s or your 30s or your 40s
actually means nothing you start
settling in - this is my life this is
how it played out I could have I should
have and what I wish is that you know
but why am I making this video probably
making it for my 50 year old self so hey
Garry 1507 yeah you step here nobody
cares if you're 40 70 90 alien female
male minority the market the market not
an individual person in your world the
market will accept your victories if
you're good enough to have a victory
there's so many people that truly are
good entrepreneurs or have
entrepreneurial DNA but they just
weren't lucky enough to be born during
an era that that seemed practical it is
super appropriate for you to start that
business that you've always wanted right
now educate yourself on the new world
yes you didn't grow up with Instagram I
didn't grow up with this [ __ ] either but
I figured it out you figured out how to
drive you figured out how to be a parent
you figured it all out so many of you
watching this
Oh big ears think back to when you were
10 from that moment until right now all
that life you've got on the back end if
you've got the right DNA and you're a 72
year old female you have just as good of
a bad as a 27 year old vote start
representing the people that actually
put in the work the gray hairs that that
contacts that knowledge start deploying
that this isn't just for the kids my
friends this is our opportunity as well
if you're 40 or older it is your time to
stand up and take advantage of your life
because there's so much this video is
made for one reason I want it to be the
calling card of the seed of the
explosion of the 40 to 80 year old
entrepreneur in our society you have a
lot more time than you think
[Music]